[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
this hour is going to be devoted to
[Music]
america's largest legalized fraud
time shares the timeshare industry has
milked primarily middle and lower income
americans completely dry to the tune of
billions and billions of dollars with
unbelievably
fraudulent sales tactics offering and
promising things that they never deliver
including an asset that is not an asset
an asset by the way by definition in
financial terms is something that you
can sell and people will give you money
for it
your couch is more of an asset
than a time share is because somebody
might actually buy
your used couch no one will buy your
timeshare
it has absolutely no value it has as
much value as your reservation
at the days in you want to try to sell
your reservation at the days inn
nope nobody wants to buy your
reservation at the day's end
and the only difference is the day's
ends actually there
and people actually do get to sleep
there occasionally that would be the
difference
if you have had a time share horror
story we're going to devote this hour to
giving you
a voice you get to speak you get to tell
your story call right now the phone
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five i wanna hear your time
share
horror stories and they will be a
warning to unsuspecting people
that otherwise might go in the tiger
cage
if you haven't heard the tiger cage is
this you're walking down the street
innocently one day and a guy runs up to
you and says hey
we're going to give you free passes
for the entire year to the zoo
in order to get those passes though you
need to spend two hours
in the tiger cage petting the tiger
warning the tiger has not been fed in
several days and he's a wee bit
greedy and hungry and so you go into the
tiger cage and you pet the tiger for two
hours which of course means you get
eaten
this is what going to a time share
presentation in order to get free
tickets to
anything is you're going in there
they're gonna keep you in there four to
twelve hours
they're going to badger the ever loving
crud out of you
they're going to use every technique and
form of pressure on the planet
and suddenly your idea of i got a free
room while i'm on vacation i got free
tickets to the water park while i'm on
vacation
has turned into the meeting from hell
and in order to just be set free from
the tiger cage
you will sign anything
one of the worst among the timeshare
companies is the largest
diamond international courthouse news
ventura california an 81 year old man
claims in court that diamond resorts
international
a timeshare club defrauded him of fifty
thousand dollars
and keeps trying to get more lewis wolf
claims diamond resorts international
club and six affiliates used high
pressure sales tactics
to open credit cards in his name run up
bills on them before the plaintiff even
realized the cards
existed and charged him more than fifty
thousand dollars for quote membership
services
in diamond resorts international
entities
wolf sued diamond resorts on march 8th
in superior court
he claims the abusive sales pitches on
the phone and in person could last four
or five hours
and despite the fifty thousand dollars
they already took from him
he says it can they continue to harass
him for upgrades
to his quote membership he's just a
senior with the sort of normal
cognitive challenges that comes from
being an
81 year old senior senior wolf's
attorney eric ridley told courthouse
news
ridley said his client is typical of
many people his age and susceptible to
high pressure sales
which can be overwhelming get this one
diamond
international sends buses to senior
communities to take them to nevada
and once they get a name there will be a
non-stop barrage of phone calls
one diamond timeshare owner told morgan
diamond is
much more ambitious and aggressive and
downright nasty in their sales
presentations
diamond just has an amazing reputation
of being rough on people they reported
845 million dollars in revenue last year
according to the times article
which cities which cites two other
lawsuits similar to wolves one in
florida
one in california so
maybe you're like the 81 year old louis
wolf
or you know someone who is or maybe you
just went in the tiger cage and you've
had an experience some of the
stories are downright funny the bizarre
behavior of some of these
timeshare sales people they are some
unusually scummy people working in an
unusually scummy business
you don't like me calling you scum well
i'll help you
you won't be scum when you go get a job
where you're not ripping people off
you're right there with payday lenders
your scum
you're screwing people and you know it
you should be ashamed of yourself your
grandmother should box your little ears
for behaving the way you're behaving
selling this crap to people
it's ridiculous and it's out of control
and it's a horrible product i hope i
haven't been unclear
if you've got a story you call me triple
eight eight two five five
two two five mario is with us in akron
ohio hey mari tell me your story
hey dave thanks for having me on today
sure um
first of all my husband michael and i
have used time shares
for over 30 years so i probably have a
little bit more information
on time shares than the average person
okay
uh one thing that you should know about
is
in addition to the maintenance fees
which
most all-time shares you are responsible
for
if you want to exchange your week you
are going to deal with either
rci which is affiliated with windom
or interval international now there is a
separate fee to belong to these
clubs as well and that's like a hundred
maybe 149
a year depending on how many years you
commit to
then when you go to exchange your week
even though you have paid your
maintenance fees
with your own company
you're going to pay these exchange
companies
249 a week if you're traveling in the
u.s
299 dollars a week if you're traveling
international oh my god why didn't you
just stay at the ritz
well it would have been cheaper what
exactly i'm just explaining to you some
of the other
fees that people don't even know yeah i
this is amazing
hey i want to hear the rest of your
story hold on with me through this break
i'll be right back with you
with what you i mean you paid 25 000 to
stay at a hotel
i mean that's what you just did this is
i mean come on people
how in the world do they get away with
this
ah because we've been letting them not
anymore they're my new hobby
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
it's a time share hour as we talk about
america's
largest legalized fraud
one company diamond international doing
almost a billion dollars a year you know
what a billion is
that's a thousand million
that's a lot of people getting ripped
off all right mari
is with us she was telling us uh that
she's been in i've been
buying and dealing with uh women i did
something wrong they're dealing with
time shares for
uh 30 years and she's talking about the
fees for the exchanges
the annual fees and then the exchange
fee per company and per transaction to
change
that's if you can get a week lined up
and you were i had to cut you off in the
middle of a commercial there so tell me
the rest of the story mari
okay well now i'm going to tell you
about somebody who has done this for 30
years
who should have been a little bit
smarter
but in february of 2018
we went to vallarta gardens for a
presentation
um this is in mexico just north of
puerto vallarta
and you know we were in the tigers cage
and we did not purchase
you know held for them no no don't want
it don't want it
well you already own some time shares at
that point right
right and we've bought nars off the
secondary market okay yes
we had owned but you know nope we didn't
want this
so these time shares are famous
for you're not getting out you've got
the exit
it's almost like the exit interview but
then
you know they bring you in something
else should have known better dave
but i paid 8 100
for travel package
it was supposed to be like on the lines
of travelocity where you're getting like
bulk airfare you know you can do things
with like viking cruise lines you know
alarms should have been going off
but the one thing that made me feel a
little bit safe
the company we bought it at vallarta
gardens in mexico
but the company was a united states
company
getaway travel services
in nebraska and i even talked to them
when i was in mexico saw the website
everything looked good
well here it is 2021
i have not been able to book any
trips with them use airfare nothing
i do still hassle them to this day
trying to get the 8 100 back i
went to the attorney general for
nebraska they couldn't do anything but
this week i did
let them know that 20 million listeners
would be finding out about their company
good good very well done okay and so the
name of this ripoff organization again
is what
getaway travel
services in nebraska and and what they
really mean is
now that we got your 8 100 would you
just get away
[Laughter]
i i am sort of a person that you know
what
i'm just going to harass them yeah i
would i would i would have 8 100
worth of fun out of it anyway messing
with just messing with him to go in
i wonder if you could buy i want to pick
an ad you could buy like in the
local paper or something in nebraska
no in puerto vallarta well
down there it's a little bit different
that's why i was glad that they were in
the united states but that really didn't
turn out to be good and
i don't know but if a tourist happened
to be looking through a tourist magazine
and
one was going to wander into the getaway
travel tiger cage and they saw your ad
that said i got screwed by getaway stay
away from them get away get away
um you know that might be fun i don't
know you can have all kinds of fun with
this you might as well because you've
been taken there's no question about
that i'm so sorry
hey thanks for sharing the story is a
warning warning
warning douglas is with us in los
angeles douglas tell us about your
timeshare
mess okay well
um we've been timeshare owners for
uh five years i'm sorry and we bought we
know that timeshare was not um it's not
a good money
investment and we went ahead and did it
because it was the first time
our whole family or my our family our
kids and myself saw
my husband relaxed and our kids are in
high school
so this is the first time he relaxed so
um we went ahead and did it it turns out
that the trip is what he relaxed not a
time share
well we've gone on trips before but this
place is just really relaxing
i'm sure there's other places but anyway
um
we
we went and um july
19th i mean july 2019 we upgraded from a
presidential
to a penthouse suite wow that must be
nice
and this how was this week um was it
nice
yes it's very nice how many times have
you stayed in
um just once because we've only
upgraded one oh i see okay
okay so anyway this last trip at the
beginning of this month
we um they put us in
a presidential suite thinking that we
had a presidential but
really we have a penthouse so we
were we wanted to upgrade you know we
wanted something bigger for our next
vacation
so we met with a salesperson on our own
will
unfortunately and um we asked her for a
copy of her contract we asked her twice
and um so we could verify what we owned
and she left the table twice both times
returning
to the table without anything in her
hand and
um instead she confirmed that we
had a presidential contract and that's
the one that we find in 2018
um which is now void
or which is void so um
she basically
um brought in the inducement
i mean she tricked us into
thinking we had a presidential when we
all the time had a penthouse
you'd already paid for the upgrade once
and then you paid for it again
exactly oh my gosh well i just want your
listeners to be yeah
which company is this this is it's
called it's in cabo san lucas it's a
small company called grand slomar
they have four properties um
three of them are right next door to
each other and then there's a brand new
one out a ways
and um i just want everyone to be
to realize what we did do is um i had a
lawyer help me with the letter
we wrote a letter um to the manager
the sales manager who's still there and
he's american
and he's the one who sold us in 2019
so we know emails we emailed him we
fedexed a letter that you have to have a
signature for they don't have certified
mail down in mexico and
within 30 days if they don't respond
favorably
we will um the letter says we will
contact the bb the better business
bureau of las vegas which that's where
their
financial handling company
is and we will open the case with the
mexican federal consumer protection
department which is called pro-feco
so i don't know how this is going to end
but um
because we just fedex the letter
yesterday but i want your listeners to
be aware that
you know we asked for that you can tell
a timeshare salesman is lying if his
mouth is moving
yes you know they they
she's she was an expert she tried she
got our trust from the get-go
we shared family stories pictures of her
kids
i mean it was just and you know
so from now on i mean we learned
we learned cheaper to stay in a hotel
you know
even if we if even if we can just recoup
our even if we give up our deposit
and we don't have to pay the rest of the
contract
i mean we'll be happy yeah i know that
sounds awful but no it doesn't sound
awful it sounds like you got screwed and
they should let you go i mean that's
what fraud does even in mexico
go figure wow amazing
what a scummy scummy business
wow this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national
guard can help you get there visit
nationalguard.com
to find out more
[Music]
we're talking time shares this hour and
what a
horrible thing they are and what
horrible people work in that business
it's absolutely out of control diamond
international westgate
marriott windham diamond being purchased
now for
billions by hilton so hilton's going to
go ahead and mess up their name by
buying the largest timeshare
company out there that screws more
people than anyone else
see what happens is people buy these
things for fifteen or twenty thousand
dollars
and they're almost never able to
actually use them
let's protect not even on the week that
they bought
this comes up time and time and time
again
the aarp put out the 10 costliest
scams to the elderly
number one romance scams 83 million
number seven time share sales 17 million
number 10 timeshare resales
12 million 30 million dollars a year
that the aarp
estimates is being stolen from
the elderly scams is what they called it
scams go figure that man
something else stacia is with us in
tampa florida hi stasia is estacia
estasi
how do you say it it's it's stacia
stacia i didn't even get close
sorry about that how can i help well
thanks for having me on your show
and um thanks for having this um i think
it's an important segment
to help get the facts out to people
before they spend money
on these programs so um back in 2001 i
received an offer in the mail
this is one that i couldn't refuse right
yeah right i think it was for 450
for five days and four nights including
a rental car and it was at a marriott
property on maui how could i pass that
up
maui i knew that a timeshare
presentation was included so my eyes
were
sort of open and i had friends that had
time shares and they seemed to enjoy it
but we never really talked about the
money part
anyway and i'm strong i'm not going to
buy a stinking time share i'm just going
to enjoy and treat my mom
to an unexpected trip to maui right
right so
we know i bought or i wouldn't be on the
segment right yeah
so you went the tiger cage and you got
eaten
oh yeah so as i was preparing for early
retirement i put it on my list of things
to do to get rid of the annual expense
um you know i could spend the money
going elsewhere and getting to hawaii
from florida
to was way too much travel so i kicked
the can down the road because i listened
to your program
now i'm not saying that you advise
procrastination
i just heard all the horror stories and
so i procrastinated because i didn't
i didn't want to deal with it which is
very rare for me
so over the years i did simple math as
soon as i was getting the value
but i corrected my simple math when i
started sending information to your show
and i learned that my simple math was
really me lying to myself
and i didn't want you to catch me in
ignoring the truth
so my original payment was for ten
thousand nine hundred dollars for every
other year to
to um stay in maui and then i upgraded
to their point system i think
that was around 2011. um i guess i
imagine the salesperson's children were
going without shoes and food or
something i don't know what i what i was
thinking
um but that upgrade was two thousand
dollars so by this time i'm in it for a
sunk cost of 12
900. i paid maintenance every year for
an every other year program
and that started at 450 dollars in 2001
and it ended at 1300 in 2020.
and in that time frame this property is
falling apart
all that maintenance well in every other
year
at occupancy so i only use it nine times
so i reached out to marriott in january
2020 and they paid me three thousand
dollars to take back my twelve thousand
dollars
twelve thousand nine hundred dollars is
current cost um
i thought it was a bargain given the
horror stories i've heard and it was
pretty simple process
marriott actually gave you three
thousand dollars
yes sir wow you really came out
but i didn't no i know you didn't but i
mean compared
i mean because marriott i mean there's
some good people that work at the hotels
and stuff
but the leadership team at marriott man
you could tell they're lying if their
mouth's moving too
oh my god we've had all kinds of trouble
with those people it's a horrible
company at the top
so i'm really shocked wow look at you
and i got out
i got out before the for the pandemic so
i don't know what that would look like
today i don't know what those fees would
raise
up to today but you did good i mean
really i mean i know you i know you feel
like you've got messed up you could get
messed over but
but i mean that's impressive if
everybody could get three thousand
dollars back from marriott that
had been screwed by marriott on a time
share well
they'd be shut down maybe it was because
it was so old you know i purchased back
in 2001
somewhere i don't know you just caught
the right person on a bad day wow
i love it that's good that's good news
well hey i'll just tell you if you're
out there and you have a marriott time
share and you went out of it i'd call
them and try to do what she did that's
pretty incredible
it'd be great if marriott got hit by
three thousand dollars for everybody
they've screwed on a timeshare
that'd be amazing i don't think they'd
be open anymore
but um that'd be amazing very cool hey
man thanks for thanks for sharing your
story
if you have a time share story
good or bad maybe you love your time
share the three percent of people do
three percent of people that have a time
share just love it
i mean what kind of come what kind of an
industry stays open with a 97
dissatisfaction ratio i mean who can
stay
no restaurant in the world i mean if you
started going okay 97
of mcdonald's customers think they suck
three percent thinks it's nutritious and
awesome you know
but they can't stay open on that right
can you imagine
i mean 97 of coca-cola drinkers hate it
how do you stay open
oh my gosh if 97 of dave ramsey
listeners
thought i was horrible they would quit
listening
hypothetically oh my gosh
that's i mean that'd be like this is
amazing
marriott here's another mayor out here's
a note i just got on marriott by the way
if you have a time sharing
story call right now triple eight eight
two five five
two two five marriott vacation club
sales people
are super trained used car sales people
this is a posting online they tell you
how easy it is to book trust me
it is all fabrication i could not book a
week
in october 11 months in advance
costs how about twenty thousand dollars
for your week of time
share seven hundred fifty dollars for
annual maintenance fees 104 dollars to
trade
your week for points 99 for interval
membership 84 to book your week and oh
yeah
79 dollars to cancel after canceling
even due to
death and immediate family you have 60
days to use your week
at a resort good luck with that
check the figures booking fancy hotels
is much cheaper
and you don't have to stay a full week
at the same location
and you get the week you want without
booking it
a full year in advance trust me
stay away from marriott vacation clubs
trust me
signed a true sucker this is an online
post right here
and this stuff just goes on and on and
on and on
and on oh here's another diamond resort
one
these guys in 2019 we were visiting a
diamond resorts location and were
offered a
discount four-day trip to palm springs
if we attended a time share presentation
while there
the staff pressured us relentlessly into
making a purchase while at the
presentation we were told that these
resorts
were for the exclusive use of members
that this was a real estate investment
it's not and that not traveling more
with our family made us
bad parents see that's when you should
have punched the guy and left
finally we felt that we needed to make a
purchase not only to leave but so that
our children could experience the
lifestyle
that the representative was promising oh
my god
after that day we continued to get
hounded with calls from diamond
employees asking us when we would be
attending a welcome presentation
every time we tried to book it nothing
was available not only can we not book
rooms that would accommodate our family
we receive bills for maintenance fees
that continue to rise
what are we continuing to pay for this
has become such a burden on us and
diamond is
unwilling to help well of course they're
unwilling to help
the tiger eats until the tiger is
full and then he yawns and
takes a nap this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
america's largest legalized fraud
timeshares we spend an hour on it
occasionally just to make sure you know
that you are getting screwed if you love
your timeshare
or you hate your timeshare or you have a
great story we'd love to talk to you the
phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
larry loves his time share hey larry how
are you
doing good day thank you cool so tell me
tell me what you like about it and where
is it
well uh we won one in branson and one in
eureka springs arkansas our first one
was eureka springs
i did have a timeshare in colorado that
i bought in a bankruptcy that was
used for skiing we went ahead and let
that one go because the
yearlies did go up but the two
i have uh the yearly fees have not gone
up over
gosh darn 25 years so what are the
what's the annual
what's the annual the one is 440 a year
the other is seven and a quarter
um for a week we use them for go ahead
so for one week yeah that's for a week
but we use them we use them to trade and
if you if you know johnny morris he owns
big cedar down in branson
their sister resort the wilderness club
is right next door we trade into their
day
yeah we enjoy the heck out of it uh
we use the branson resort strictly for
family reunions that we go to yearly
and and we've we've traded all over the
country but we've
we've as i told the screener you know my
father did not vacation
and when i got out of seminary school
third four um our very first time here
down in
eureka springs the gentleman was very
low pressure
he gave us the tour he said we're not
high pressure here
go have dinner if this is something you
like come back tomorrow we'll pay
we'll sign papers and and we liked what
we saw and
for us the experience was wonderful now
those are those
independently owned or they owned by one
of these other companies that we were
talking about
uh well they're you know they're they're
related rci
the resort exchange company but that's
just an association that's not they
don't they're they're in
who owns them uh
i see well the homeowners as far as
holiday island
down in eureka springs and in branson
the unit owners you know it's
i couldn't tell you who owns it per se
all i know is it's been good to us
because we've known how to use it you
know
so you bought one of them point of sale
you bought it on the property
did you buy the and you bought one out
of bankruptcy that you let go out in
colorado
the the other one did you buy it on the
property or did you buy it on out of
bankruptcy we did
we did uh down in branson we bought that
one on property
okay um and um
i'll be honest we wish we'd gone out to
the wilderness club first
because the wilderness club is
absolutely beautiful um
right on lake uh right on table rock
lake and
if folks are you know folks are
listening they know what i'm talking
about
um but but again i understand the times
time share scam i've had quite a few
clients
that we've talked about it but uh you
know i've i've sold my weeks to clients
they've gone down there and enjoyed the
heck out of them
i've used them for auctions in churches
and the
parishioners have used them and so i've
i've had a
variety of reasons for using mine
i definitely understand the scams what
did you what did you pay for them up
front
uh the eureka springs we paid 4 500
the bankruptcies were 1700. now branson
at grand crown uh was 12 grand
okay um and and so
uh but i had specific reasons uh we
weren't you know
we knew what we were getting into when
we bought them and we go to a nice place
every year for our reunion uh
we trade into we trade into the
wilderness club every january and take a
week off before we start our
our practices for the year it's a r
r for us and and we get the shelter for
the family and
um you don't want to leave that resort i
mean
look up look up big cedar and you'll
understand johnny morris doesn't do
anything wrong
i understand got you cool well i'm glad
you're liking it good i appreciate your
reporting in that's fair
that's a fair part of the part of the
story as well we appreciate you
thanks larry appreciate you sharing that
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five if you have a time
share
story according to a survey done
by the university of central florida
87 of people hate their time shares
according to a study done by the
timeshare industry 87 percent of people
love their time
i wonder who's telling the truth
and we saw a survey the other day a
different one that was 97 that i
referenced earlier we're actually doing
some research right now in the timeshare
industry ramsey research our research
arm and i
can't wait to get to report that to you
guys it's gonna be amazing
uh our guys are they know how to do the
actual research it'll be it'll be
straight now it won't just be let's
confirm dave's opinion
no they actually get real solid
statistical evidence of exactly what is
going on in the marketplace we do it for
all kinds of things
and around the money space and where we
get we see the consumer getting screwed
wholesale like this then we uh we want
to step in and
find out what's really happening because
see people like hilton are
buying diamond and these executives that
made all this money
all these years are getting a
real payday when hilton comes in and
buys that company out
so this is uh this is ding ding for them
they are ringing the bell at the bar
like they do when they get a tip
yeah and it's i got a lot of zeroes on
it
it's amazing how much money those guys
are made off of
you andrew's in indianapolis hi andrew
welcome to the ramsey show tell me your
story
hi dave how are you great how can we
help
um yeah a couple of years ago um
probably 2013. i know 2014. i'm sorry
we my wife and i went to tennessee on a
timeshare
that my sister-in-law and brother-in-law
gave us for our anniversary along with
our two
very little kids and um
so you were using their week yes sir we
were using their week
in the gatlinburg or pigeon forge area
where in tennessee
uh gatlinburg to be uh to be specific
yeah it's got time sure crawling all
over it like termites
okay yes it does and uh so we had
uh my daughter was three at the time my
son was probably maybe one and a half
two at the oldest
and they told us oh it'll be just a 30
45 minute meeting or so
and i kind of rolled my eyes it's been
like i've heard this before but okay
we'll
we'll bite the bulb we already told you
no but okay we'll just
you know they trick you with that little
gift or so
and uh what was the gift what was the
gift to get you into the meeting
uh you know what it must have not been
that big of a deal because i don't
remember it actually okay
uh i just it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
30 minutes how long were you in there
uh we were there for five and a half
hours
very little children yes
and at the one point or so uh so uh
the salesperson he was very nice very
nice and as soon as we started saying no
and he started realizing we weren't
interested
it flipped on a dime and he became the
most hateful person to us
he even called over his manager and
the manager got really angry with us or
so at the
time my three-year-old she was getting
very fussy
and he kind of gave her a very dirty
look at the and
i'm very normally a very quiet reserved
person or so my wife said that uh
it looked like i went i kind of blacked
out and i got up
i said don't you ever talk to my child
like that ever again
looked at my wife said grab the kids we
are leaving i said if you
bar me from this thing i will not
hesitate to call the local authorities
wow so you walked out it was a very
i'm sorry what so after five and a half
hours you walked out after they were
rude to you and finally
call it called down your kid yes
yeah you remember the company name uh
no it uh the place we were staying at it
was blue green it was
that's the company of them yeah blue
green is number four
um they're the number four largest one
and they they get more complaints
oh my god what a horrible company wow
yeah
oh my gosh well there it is folks
this is the timeshare share industry
if you look up scum in the dictionary
you'll see their picture
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice can coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the proximity
principle is my co-host today
open phones at 825-5225
that's triple eight eight two five five
sarah is going to start us off this hour
in saratoga springs new york hi sarah
how are you
hi dave hi ken how are you great how can
we help
great um my husband and i are on baby
step
3b and we just closed on a house and we
were wondering how soon after we moved
into the house should we
restart the retirement again
well what do you think i think about
three to four months so we can get used
to the new budget in the house but my
husband feels anxious that we haven't
been putting it into retirement and he
wants to start it
as soon as possible yeah why would you
wait
um just because the house payment and
house expenses are a little bit
different
than what it is in our apartment so i
just wanted to get a better handle on
what it's actually going to be per month
well you want to know
they gave you the payment amount at the
closing
true what is it you're going to discover
i guess of like repairs and stuff like
that
you just bought the house does it need
repairs
it's just like a new furnace it's like a
25 year old furnace so they suggested
um replacing it soon so we were gonna do
that within the first couple months
okay get some bids on a furnace
okay so here's the thing okay you you
you should not have
all of these unknowns and then
once you don't have the unknowns then
that tells you when you can start the
retirement or should start the
retirement
but i'm with your husband i've got an
urgency to get going on it but i don't
want to start your retirement and then
finance a furnace
so you know i know but the balance is we
got to figure out how we're going to pay
for this furnace right
and so go ahead and get you know we know
what the pain house payment is
and uh shouldn't be hard to pull up the
electric bill you can get copies of that
from the former owner or even ask the
utility company they'll give you the
history on that so you'll be able to lay
your budget out within a few dollars
and then you say then you get three bids
on the furnace and you go okay we're
going to spend x number of dollars on a
furnace and so
that's going to mean we start the retire
we start retirement back after the
furnace is saved and that's going to be
here
you ought to be able to lay all of this
out but but the idea we're going to kick
the can down the road for
vague unknowns that you should search
out the answer to is not a good plan
okay does that make sense to you total
sense yeah so go ahead and just dial it
in and
if you get dialed in you're okay ken
yeah and you know one other thing i'd
say there is
who's they and let's get two or three
days to look at that furnace and say
do we need to replace it now or do we
think it's got six months to your life
go ahead and save up for it get the
quote of what it's going to cost get
three four quotes
and save it up but i i've been scared
before dave i remember when i was a new
homeowner
and i all you need to do this you need
to do that well you need to do this
well do we really yeah that's all you're
still gonna save up for it prepare for
it stinking thing might last five years
it could be the efficiency on it too
would be worth going ahead and doing it
but you also want to catch it on
seasonality that's true meaning you
don't want to you don't want to
do a replacement when uh there's a line
of people out the door doing
replacements
because because the season changed right
that's correct you want to do it in the
off season where they're
catching when they're not working and
they give you a good deal yeah and so
the timing on it would be a good idea
too but you're right
you can go ahead and save up and be
ready for executing on a certain timing
or just be ready when the thing lays
down to fix it
at that point anthony's with us anthony
is in
tampa florida hi anthony welcome to the
ramsay show
hey dave such an honor to chat with you
how you doing you do how can we help
um just wondering on which baby step
can we start updating kitchen updating
pool
that kind of thing well we teach folks
to not do anything
until they're through baby step three
out of debt
and have your emergency fund in place
because updating the kitchen is not an
emergency
so you need your emergency fund in place
and be out of debt first
now then at the point that you're at
baby steps four five and six you move
from intense meaning not doing anything
except those things
to intentional
and intentional means that there's some
other stuff in our life we're gonna do
while we're doing retirement kids
college and paying extra on the house
but we're also going on vacation buy new
couch update the kitchen do the pool
whatever
those things get woven into the budget
at that point of course paying
cash for them and but um right there's a
different rhythm there ken in those uh
three
in four five six yeah i like the
distinction between
intense and then intentional you know
okay look we just talked about this a
previous caller
we've got some real expenses what would
we consider higher priority what's lower
priority what's just
well we'd really like to do it but it's
really not going to affect our life
negative or positive one way or the
other and i think that's the
intentionality that you're speaking to
and i got to tell you that's really
helped us from time to time go well i
want this
but we don't need this good distinction
the king coleman show
is broadcast on 75 plus radio stations
siriusxm and as a podcast
every day he is helping folks with their
careers with their jobs
with their promotions with uh finding
their dream with finding work
that matters and plugging in every day
does that
recruiters spend an average of 7.4
seconds on an initial resume screening
gosh that's probably double what i spend
and uh it's never been more difficult
for your resume to stand out among the
sea of participants
and that's why we uh ken created a six
easy to use resume templates
to get you noticed uh there are a whole
9.99
six of them and these are instructions
for building your resume the 10 do's and
don'ts of job applications
text resume to 33 789
you can get dialed in on that resume two
three three
seven eight nine and of course you can
follow ken
on the ken coleman show on facebook
ken coleman on instagram making coleman
show on youtube
he's everywhere helping people with
their careers including here today to
help you if you want to talk careers
jump in at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five kelsey says in my office there's a
job opening
that would be considered a promotion
what can i do to show my boss i'm
qualified
yeah i love this i sit down with them uh
after we've looked at the actual job
description and make sure you are
qualified you just don't want to be
qualified
in this uh particular question it's all
right we're going to sit down
if you've got the qualifications and go
hey i'm really interested in this
opportunity
here's why don't just lead with
qualifications
lead with enthusiasm see this is what a
leader wants to know they want to know
not just that you're qualified but
you're raising your hand not just for a
promotion for
you but because you are really really
deeply excited about this opportunity to
grow yourself
by adding more value to the company
they're going to go for enthusiasm
some passion more than just
qualification
and lay it out there i'm really
interested i want the shot what can i do
to get the shot
man coach that's it but hunger right not
with an attitude of
hey give me the thing i'm the guy that
you're supposed to put in the game no
i want the shot coach coach i'll prove
it that's it i'll prove it hunger
got this i got it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money on the stage the
debt-free stage
in the lobby of ramsey solutions
is benjamin and josefa hi guys how are
you
thank god we're good how are you better
than i deserve
my friend where do you live we're from
philadelphia pennsylvania oh cool
welcome to nashville
and all the way here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off
seventy three thousand forty six dollars
very good
and how long did this take you 28 months
all right
and your range of income during that
time uh 136 000 to 143
very good what you do for a living i
work in sales
what do you sell uh so we help
pharmaceutical companies
uh with a quality system okay cool i'm a
stay-at-home mom
wonderful yeah okay very good what kind
of debt was your 73 000
student loans yay she got rid of sallie
mae
yeah i was so happy to say goodbye to
that toss her out in the street where
she belongs
i love it so what's how long you guys
been married
almost six years okay so two years ago
in some change
something changed what happened well
um we have been on a financial journey
since the beginning of our marriage
and actually it's funny because um when
right before i got married with
tabinyamin my friend was telling me
about this snowball thing
i'm like oh okay guess i guess that that
is bad
so we were actually living in brooklyn
new york and we moved to philly
philadelphia with the intention of
buying a home so
we for we decided for one year we'll
rent and then we started our home search
a year later
and none of the homes looked really
great
um and then one day benjamin comes home
and i'll let him finish the story
so i came home because i had a long
conversation with a couple of friends of
mine
and realized that we're about to
undertake getting a house and we still
have over 70 thousand dollars worth of
debt left
and that doesn't really make sense if
you have to replace a roof that's going
to cost you ten thousand dollars and
we're never to set up
a financially successful life for our
families so we had a pretty difficult
conversation for the next couple of days
we bought the most of your books started
religiously listening to the podcast and
then decided okay we're going to do this
and we set out on a trek from there
to to knock out the next the rest of the
debt how did you run into our stuff
i had a friend i have a couple of
friends in philadelphia that are strong
adherents
and so it was a lengthy conversation you
know
we it was hard to get not be on the
house buying train like everybody else
yeah
uh and say you know we were in the same
boat as everybody else and
it kind of came to the realization that
this doesn't make sense right now yeah
very cool very cool well congratulations
you guys
i'm proud of you very well done who were
your uh biggest
cheerleaders cheering you on along the
way our family
they're definitely supportive and it was
really good to have friends kind of in
the same boat as us
like living the dave ramsey lifestyle
and
having that yeah fun so you got a bunch
of people doing it
oh yeah very cool so i gotta i gotta ask
you buy the books you start listening
daily to the show and so you're really
starting to soak all this
in what were some of the first big steps
maybe a big momentum starter for you to
get started on this debt snowball
and really get some traction what'd you
guys do but we had to make the first
difficult choice to take all the money
that we had put
to the house and throw it into that yeah
that's hard
and so that was that was hard i mean
honestly a process of becoming
comfortable with your lot we had to
decide
for the next three years or however long
it's gonna take we're gonna live in an
apartment instead of where everybody
else is going to buy houses
we're going to be comfortable and and
and make do with what we have and be
happy with it
and so i mean the first biggest step was
just the the mental state
of being willing to to do that and kind
of getting on the same page
i mean once you're on the same page it's
a lot easier yeah um and so
that was really the first part of the
process yeah i have to admit it took me
a little bit
to get onto that page but once i did i
was definitely happy
um well you were on the house train oh
yeah it was really disappointing to
say no to them yeah but um
the budget part was really important but
as you can tell from when benjamin
mentioned his range of income not much
changed it was more of a mindset that
had to change
you know we were dealing with a similar
budget we just had to differentiate
between
the things that we needed and the things
that we wanted to have and we'd like to
have
and the impulse buys that we wanted to
do so
um that was definitely a difficult
mindset change
yeah that's a big deal that's a big deal
so how's it feel now that you're free
it's it's actually i listen to the show
a lot of times the typical answers are
and it's true for us too
it's liberating it's freeing it's like a
weight off your shoulders
a friend of mine made an interesting
comment to me who started the ramsey
journey for himself
which is that i you know and we felt the
same way i thought that freedom really
is the ability to buy what i want
but it's not really because the freedom
is actually the ability to make
unencumbered choices
and freedom really lives kind of in that
mindset where you have a structure
you have you know you have the baby
steps you have a plan
and you find freedom within that when
you don't have the plan you don't have a
structure
you actually end up buying a bunch of
stuff you don't need you end up spending
more than you actually make
and so it's actually the true freedom is
within that structure and once you get
to the end of it then you really have
the ability
to make unencumbered choices okay so
that's you know true freedom
hey man that's good yeah i mean that's
like i'm gonna
take the next segment you should that's
a great great visual too to that word
that's a 50 cent word but the reality is
it's it's there's no strings it's
nothing holding you back
yeah that's a beautiful beautiful
illustration powerful
now you brought friends with you who are
the friends just off camera over here
well we got our family
oh your family three kids um and
also my father and my brother and his
family also
oh very good quite a quite a family
affair then
yeah brought the cheering gallery very
good good well we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you and a copy of the
total money makeover you can pass those
along and enjoy them yourself and
oh here they come i love it what are the
babies names and ages
so this is minaj mendel he's eight
months this is endogetous she's two and
a half
and this is ellie as her lab five
fabulous
they look fun oh they are very cool very
cool
i love it well congratulations you guys
thank you very very well done
all right benjamin and josefa 73
000 paid off in 28 months making 136 to
143
they are now unencumbered they are they
are debt-free
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
i love it that's fun look at those
babies they're cute
very well done that's a great family and
great story
completely free you know there's a lot
said in that interview with them
this idea that i can just
i it was a decision and once we made the
decision
all the drama goes away and it funny
where all the drama and anc are
comes from is not staying with the
decision yes
you know proverbs says a double-minded
man yes is unstable
in all his ways and we add drama to our
lives when we don't stick with
okay we're going to do this we're going
to stick with it
then all the other stuff's off the table
and it just all of the emotion and the
psychology and the drama and stuff
starts to melt away doesn't it it really
does in fact the rest of that scripture
talks about the the analogy of driven
like the waves and the wind of the sea
you know just this back and forth back
and forth
and committing to the decision and then
managing the decision once the decision
is made
we manage our behavior based on the
decision i'll tell you one other thing
that
that i heard dave that i thought was
really cool for those of you that listen
to the show and you're debt free and
you're still part of this
amazing community of people that was it
was a friend
who was on their own debt free journey
that said whoa slow down on that house
purchase slow down
and a friend said hey maybe consider
this and because of that friend and
group of friends they discovered
financial peace don't forget that as
you're going through a journey and
you're getting freedom and hope
to share that with others you may be the
lifeline
that they needed that'll move things
along for sure very good stuff
well done their heroes are awesome love
it love it love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host
today kristy wright our co-host in crime
another ramsey personality has launched
the pre-sale of her brand new book take
back your time the guilt-free guide to
life balance for years christie was
stretched way too thin
uh she has a mom of three with a
full-time career she realized something
had to change
and she took a long hard look at her
life and she figured out why she felt
overwhelmed and why she felt over
committed all the time
and she figured out that balance is
about doing the right things
at the right time the new book is take
back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance if you pre-order right
now while it's on sale it comes out in
september
you get fifty dollars worth of free
bonus items it includes the audiobook
read by christy the e-book
access to the take back your time live
stream
and a lot more so all you do is go to
ramseysolutions.com pre-order your copy
of christy's new book take back your
time
and get it done today ken we've got a
big announcement coming up next week on
your new stuff
oh exciting can't tell about it but yeah
i know it's like a secret
big secret not really i need to stop or
dave's got this little button he pushes
shock me right here be great television
now they they've got a button in there
they push they it's the eject button and
i go out through the roof when i
launch something sooner than it's
supposed to launch i get launched
look how much enjoyment james and
kelly's faces of the idea of their
just licking their chops their
proverbial chops
yes indeed ah jared is in irvine
california hi
jared welcome to the ramsay show hey mr
randy how's it going
better than i deserve sir what's up in
your world
hey so uh i was just calling with a
question for you
um i'm looking to get some guidance as
to whether or not i should
sell my house and move up
or if i should stay where i'm at with a
smaller space
i'll give you a little background real
quick we're in a two-bedroom condo right
now and we have
two small children so the boys are
sharing a room
um and we're gonna be trying for a third
here real soon so
that's why i'm having the debate of do i
sell
in this awesome seller's market and try
to move up and maybe stretch our budget
a little thin
or do i just suck it up and try to cram
three kids in a two-bedroom condo
yeah are you out of debt except the
condo
uh yes we're in baby steps four five and
six good
okay when you make the move up are you
going to do it on a 15-year fixed where
the payment's no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay
uh yes that's the plan if you can do
that i don't have anything my
question too just trying to figure out
how much exactly i can afford without
you know stretching too far 25 of your
take-home pay is a payment
on a 15-year fixed rate
and if you do that you know you're not
gonna be stretched too thin
you're gonna be okay the problem gets in
is because let me tell you the mortgage
company
will approve you for almost twice that
much
almost twice that much to where as much
numbers i'll move you over to a 30 from
a 15 and then they'll jam that ratio
all the way as high as they can jam it
up in the high 30s uh up close to 40
percent of your take-home pay
and uh and then you're on a 30-year
mortgage and now you're owned
by them which is the goal instead what
we're our goal is to get you into the
mortgage and get you into that house and
get you back out of that mortgage
and that's why we do a 15-year fix let's
get it paid off in 10 then
and have a game plan to get at it but it
does sound like you need to move dude
you've got kids coming out everywhere
it's just like
you got you got a whole stack of them
there man the two boys in the room you
can manage that
third one for a pair third one changes
that whole equation yeah
yeah and it's it's obviously getting
tight in there but um
yeah you just can't use the old i'm in
california excuse because
you know the math still works in
california
um in spite of what some of the
politicians say
math still works in california so it's
still what has to happen there hey
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five tiffany's
next in austin texas hi tiffany how are
you
hi mr ramsey i'm a new listener and um a
colleague has suggested that i
i call in today okay
um so recently i've been really focusing
on
paying off my debt with my husband and
this morning i was
um served um papers from a student loan
that i thought was
no longer my responsibility it was a
private student loan that i had gotten
out years ago with my deceased
grandfather
i have at the time we couldn't afford to
pay it back when my grandfather
passed away newly married and then i
started disputing it on
my credit report on both transunion and
equifax
and each time i disputed it it came back
that it was not
my debt and it has since come off
all of my credit reporting over the last
three to four years
um it did i did notice whenever i got
served this morning i went and checked
and it was
on my equifax report um
but i'm just not sure what to do with
this thing i've never been sued or
anything like that and that kind of
scares you doesn't it
yeah i'm a little bit emotional today so
i told my husband i'm going to call i
don't want to cry and my mom just passed
away
a few months ago so i'm like i'm going
to cry that's okay i'm sorry
so how much is the debt um
so the random thing is there's actually
two of them but they are only sending it
for one it's uh
twelve thousand nine hundred and thirty
dollars and eighty cents
okay well here's the equation
if you signed a contract
saying that you owe the debt when you
took it out
with your grandfather then you
are liable whether it's on your credit
bureau report or not
does not affect your legal liability
you can have something that is never on
your credit bureau report and you're
legally liable because you signed a
contract
saying you would pay it if however your
grandfather signed it
and you're listed as the person who got
the money for college but
you did not sign the agreement then you
are
not liable and you will need an attorney
so we don't know based on what you've
told me do you have any documents from
any of this
yeah i'm looking at it it does have me
as signature of borrower
and then it has my grandfather's
signature of co-signer
okay so you're looking at the actual
loan agreement
not the lawsuit i'm
looking at the lawsuit they have several
exhibits
okay and one of the exhibits is the
original loan document
correct and it has you as the borrower
it is you as the borrower
okay well i'm sorry you're liable
you signed as a borrower how old were
you when you signed that
um oh six i can't even do that math
right now
uh 23. okay okay you're you're over 18
so you're liable okay i'm not an
attorney but that's the correct answer
all right when you sign a loan document
as the borrower
that means you're liable to pay it does
that make sense
yes so here's what we're going to do
they say 12 000 bucks you all have any
money
we can no how much money do you have do
you have any money
saved right now i think our savings
account maybe has 1500
in it what can you scrape together
beyond that
um my next big check will be in november
and so i'll have an additional ten
thousand dollars
okay uh
so you have a debt of twelve thousand
dollars that's what they're suing you
for correct
correct okay so i'm and and this is how
many years ago
from 2006 2006.
15 years okay so
yeah i would call them and say i don't
have any money
i'm broke i just got served i didn't
even realize i was liable until i read
this exhibit
i do have fifteen hundred dollars if you
will accept that as
settlement in full we can settle this
today
they probably won't take that
but you probably can get it for about 25
cents on the dollar
not 10 cents on the dollar so if you can
scrape together another 1500 bucks you
probably can settle this and for about 3
000 bucks
if you can get them to agree to that on
the phone you get that
in writing you do not give them
electronic access to your checking
account
and then you wire them the money
directly or you send them a money order
or a prepaid debit card or something
that does not interfere with your
regular
monies but scrape together a couple of
thousand bucks here
two to three thousand dollars i think
you can talk them into taking that
as a settlement in full get it in
writing
before you send it to them and do not
let them into your personal checking
account
as a part of the deal
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
troy and holly are with us hey guys how
are you awesome
welcome where do you guys live we're
from goshen indiana
ocean south bend area yes all right i
think i see a notre dame thing on here
yeah yeah i didn't know if i needed to
hide that there it is
we allow almost anybody in here
welcome so you're here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off
we paid off 65 000 in 30 months
very good and your range of income
during that time actually went from
52 000 to 48 000. oh
down oh yeah there's a story here huh
yeah there's a little story i'm a high
school math teacher and i was a varsity
boys basketball coach for eight years
and
um actually decided to step down during
our debt-free um
journey i just felt as you'll see a
little bit our kids and our family was
growing we have five kids and
just felt like it was time to take a
step back and it was cool to see god
work out
the details of when we actually took
less income and had some other things
pop up during that time
very cool good for you what kind of debt
was the 65 000
it was all our house oh you paid off
your house
we're looking at weird people yes you
are how old are you
guys i am 37 and my wife is 36.
wow that's awesome paid for house man
you're so weird
what's this house worth uh i would say
in the market we're in
well i say 180 to 200 somewhere in there
i'll go with that
very good man that's whack you're not
even 40 and you have a paid for
house tell us about this journey what
happened two and a half years ago made
you guys lean into this
well it doesn't it really starts 16
years ago so 16 years ago
next month will be our anniversary our
16 year anniversary and
um like this is a god story we're we're
on our honeymoon
16 years ago driving to tennessee and
driving down to florida later on
and back in those days we didn't use our
phone to listen to podcasts and
everything we were using the old seek
and scan button on the radio
yeah usually i'm just looking for radio
in your car yeah it's amazing right and
we're just looking for some good music
to listen to and whatever and
this guy comes on the radio it's a talk
show he's talking about plastectomies
he's talking about baby steps uh
he's talking about debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage is
taking the place of the bmw as a status
symbol of choice and
it caught me right away and i had never
heard of you before that and
um i'm like i'm i'm getting it so when
we got back home off our honeymoon we
did the old google search and found out
that you were on in our area just never
knew it and so
started listening to the show and um for
16 years we've just been slowly slowly
making good decisions and it ends in
this
very cool very cool so you whittled away
and walked all the way through the baby
steps
yeah essentially when we we had bought
we had bought in a used car right before
we got married
um i put it on on the payments because
we didn't know any better right and
right away i hear you talking about
that's not okay and so
uh once i graduated college and we were
able to
um you know have my teacher income and
so on we started attacking
uh the car and then my student loans at
that point we've been debt free
um from that probably 12 plus years and
then
i knew at some point we wanted to get
you know the house
that was the big one and so 30 months
ago is where the story comes in 30
months ago it was my birthday
i would have been turning 35 and i just
we had 65 000 left on the morgan and i
looked and said i want this done by the
time i'm 40.
and we literally took out some old
construction paper made a a
house that we colored in every month the
kids got involved in that and that
we put it on our bathroom door and every
month i just look forward to getting
that thing and that became our
motivation and
um i said i want to do it before i'm 40
and i'm turning 38 next month so it was
just
amazing to see to see god work out the
details on that journey
did you step away from coaching yes yeah
that's that's a sacrifice i know a lot
of coaches
a lot of coaches a lot of a lot of
coaches that they couldn't
they couldn't conceive of not being a
coach and i can see that you you love
coaching first to step aside like that
to spend more time with the family and
that's a big sacrifice talk about
how that paid off and and where that
goes from there yeah um
i think what i've learned is in life
whether
i love coaching you know and um when i
put in god's hands and and
follow even if it doesn't feel right or
seem right yeah you believe in his hands
things work out and
um you know like this summer i was able
to coach my son's little league next
year i'll coach a seventh grade
basketball team instead of the varsity
basketball team that my son is on
and being able to still do what i love
in a different avenue with less pressure
less time
and still being around my family so
follow up to that so i'm reading into
what you said
so you step back from coaching that's
where the pay went down correct but then
you said god brought some other pay in
yeah
so um that that that would just be my
teaching salary that i mentioned but i
work at a golf course in the summers and
pick up odds and ends and um again
here's another god thing so the year
that i i quit high school coaching
um had no intent of going to the college
game and labor day i quit in april
and in labor day weekend i get a call
from a college coach saying i need an
assistant i'm desperate will you help me
out
and wasn't planning on that but i did do
college coaching for a year
and ended up financially being blessed
more than what the high school
was so just to see that's cool a lot of
people don't know that part of the story
wow pretty cool well done how's it feel
holly not have a payment
it feels amazing freeing
what's the first big thing you guys are
going to do now that you don't have a
house payment
i think we want to save up for a family
cruise maybe that's a good plan
i like that one and just just that for
me like we've said no
so many times you know on this just the
little things just i look forward to the
yeses that i can give my kids now
that's powerful yeah no no means yes
later
that's what it means if you live like no
one else later you can live and give
like no one else
i love it very cool what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
you've been on a long journey here
um i would say just persistence and it
it seems like you'll never get there but
you do and one day you're just like wow
that just happened
that little that little construction
house up there on the door is done
yes it is and and i want to i want to
take a special shot to my wife because
we haven't talked about what she does
um she has the harder job she stays home
right and she does some homeschooling
with our kids and
we have foster care and adoption in our
story as well yeah and she's the real
hero um
you know i'm off able to do what i want
with teaching and coaching and doing
those things but when she stays home
and takes care of the family and is able
and
and financially we have been on the same
page all of our marriage i don't think
we've ever had a money fight and just to
have a wife that
is on the same page and um the day that
like
the amount that we owed in the house
minus our
emergency fund that day that we could we
had the money to do it
like lump sum let's finish this baby off
i get home from school i'm like babe
like it's there we can take it out and
the emergency fund is still there
and i'm just kind of waiting for that
day and seeing what she would say and
like instantly she's like we'll get to
the bank right now like let's go
and so just to have a teammate that has
been like that has just been awesome
yeah she's a real hero well done you
guys well done very proud of y'all
who are your biggest cheerleaders
outside the two of you
yeah i was going to say it's mostly been
ourselves but we definitely have people
that
are supportive and they're definitely
happy when we talk about it
so we've been blessed that's good very
cool
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that's what you've done you've
changed this whole family tree
financially
well done and also a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away and
start someone on their journey that i
like that crazy guy on the radio
all those years ago as you were driving
through tennessee go figure yeah
very very cool good for you guys so you
brought the kiddos with you and let's
put them into the shot
and give me their names and ages
so kylie is almost 14. um
drew is 12. jeremiah's 11.
brayden is eight and cameron is he's
almost five but he's four
all right very cool so good to have you
guys a good looking family well done
well done well done
all right it's troy and holly and the
tribe from south bend indiana
area 65 000
paid off in 30 months that's the house
and everything
making 52 down to 48. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
all right you guys ready to god be all
the glory honor and praise
three two one
[Applause]
high fives all around dave that's
awesome that's how i love it that's how
coach does it at his house
i love it very very cool stuff
absolutely amazing yeah good looking
family
yeah oh it's so fun there's something uh
about having the whole family celebrate
yeah you can see a lot of teamwork
between that husband and wife
certainly with the kids getting it
that's a special moment that wasn't just
a performance there
they're genuinely happy the way they're
giving themselves away
through foster care adoption and just
they've set a course dave that as you
know
it's gonna be hard to keep that family's
legacy down it's only 50 000 bucks a
year
they don't have a house payment no sir
they don't have a house payment yeah
this is pretty incredible yeah i mean
they really have pulled off something
here that's a pretty
on a teacher salary yeah there it is
again those teachers they pop up
everywhere
i love it i love it very well done that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books good hour ken good hour james
childs our producer
kelly daniel our associate producer and
phone screener i am dave ramsey your
host
and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five marie starts off this
hour in
washington dc hi marie how are you
i'm great thank you how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
um my husband and i don't know when we
should buy a house
we're on baby steps four and five we're
renting right now but my husband's
company is relocating us
next june and we we don't know when to
buy
our three thoughts were start looking in
the fall
before we move maybe buy so we have
plenty of time and we're not pressured
and then we have a place to land once we
move
the second is either moving with our
in-laws for a couple of months next june
and then buy and then the third option
is maybe move in june rent for six
months
and then in that six month period um
buy a house but we don't know what we
should do
my husband doesn't really want to rent
anymore because he just wants to start
building equity
um why do you have to start looking in
the fall
to buy a house by june
that sounds fairly inefficient to me
well i think he just wants to see what's
available because the market's so
hot and if there's something that we'd
like we would just rather buy it
and then have our in-laws who live there
sort of watch it and go
if or if we have construction or so
you're going to just
piss away six months worth of house
payments
you know we would pay the the i know
you're just burning it you just put 100
bills in the middle of the kitchen table
and set them on fire
okay for what
why can't you i mean let me tell you
what a normal procedure would be
if i'm gonna move in june i make a trip
over in february and start looking
okay and close something like may
okay and then i move entered in june
okay cause she's thinking of like going
to on a house hunting trip
and like seeing a few places in october
i know why if you want to go over there
just for the fun of it that's fine
but you don't need to buy a house in
october that you're not moving into
until june it doesn't make any sense at
all
so we wouldn't necessarily buy right in
october like just to look and maybe
something comes up in january
okay buy in may start looking and buy in
may
and move in in june that way you're not
paying a house payment for a house
that's just sitting there
because you got the itch okay
and you're paying rent by the way back
where you are right i know i know i
guess this is also what has been
thinking that's
what like a lot is happening all at once
so if we can have a place
to land then it's not okay you do
whatever you want to do
but that's weird all right yeah and i
would just say option three is a viable
option i get that your hubs doesn't want
to rent but
you know there's a lot of things i don't
want to do that i still do because
they're the best thing to do and if
you're stressed out about it go rent
and get your bearings when stacy and i
moved back here seven years ago
we rented for a year because we had kids
we want to make sure that it was the
best school situation the best
neighborhood
so we took our time and we had a place
to land because we were renting
and then we're able to take our time and
walk
uh really wisely through the process
uh in your position i don't know why you
wouldn't consider renting other than he
doesn't want to
yeah but either way dave's answer is
just as good
it's okay i mean you can rent for six
months and buy during that time
uh or you can uh just move in may
yeah right that's when
you're moving anyway it's me so buy a
house moving me
and you know and so and then dial back
out of that that means i might start
looking in march or april
and with a you know with a possession of
sometime in may
upon the closing that kind of a thing
that's a fairly normal process yeah
there's fear all over that to where you
said the same thing three different ways
and there's fear that's covering that up
not picking on her but it's fear and
part of it's going well the the market
we've got to move now i got news for you
based on what i would be better off
you'll be better off to buy them the
market
is i'm not saying it's peaking but it's
not going to
keep going up up up the way it has been
i think about everything is calming down
it really is this it was a coveted blip
and it's calming down it's not
it's going to continue real estate goes
up in value yeah
that's right but it's you know the idea
that it's going to double between now
and may
is ridiculous it's not going to denver's
an expensive market anyway yeah but um
it's not going to double you're going to
be okay marie buy a house
when you need the house not six months
before
that's unwise that was
a gentler way of saying it gabriel is in
canada hi gabriel how are you
hey guys you're awesome cool how can we
help
jim i have a question uh so i'm looking
to get married next year
um to my girlfriend but uh her dad's
um very considerate with
like uh making sure that i could support
her good um like financially
good can you i think um uh
well she was in switzerland um so
i kind of need to find a job there first
but the plan
was to save up 25 000
and then with that money we could get
married move in
uh rent a place um so i was just
wondering what you guys think about that
plan
why do you need twenty five thousand
dollars to go to switzerland
no like for the wedding um why it's
funny
yeah okay are you working you gotta you
got the money to do that
uh as of now i have around 11 000 but
yeah i'm working
okay so you're well on your way then i
think all you're gonna need is a job
that makes as much as you make now
in the area of switzerland
right okay and do you think twenty five
thousand dollars
enough for all those things
for a wedding and what else wedding
rent like first months rent we want two
months expenses
we basically want to go into a debt free
yeah
yeah i mean it'd be great to have your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses if you
have those dialed in and you know where
they're going to be that'd be wonderful
and pay cash for the wedding um it all
matters you know
it's not enough if your wedding's thirty
thousand but it's plenty if your wedding
is ten thousand
yeah you know it's all about the wedding
budget as to whether that 25 works or
not
i don't know where how much of that
you're going to spend on the wet on the
wedding so
um i like the conversation that you're
having with her dad
that means you're a young man of honor
and
um her dad is stretching
you and her to do this the right way
that's cool
it is it's it's good to see that and you
know real quick thing here i would
adjust the i would adjust the wedding
budget
based on if you're going to be hustling
to get to 25 let's adjust that budget
you know i mean you can always do
uh great trips as we get together in
marriage we're debt free we stay debt
free we live like no one else
the cost of weddings dave can get really
outrageous quickly
i've heard the rumor
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well if you're struggling with debt
you know what it's like to be scared you
know what it's like to be overwhelmed
where you can't even think straight i've
been there too
you don't have to live like that anymore
when you pay off all your debt as fast
as possible you will never have that
kind of stress in your life again
and you can do this here's where you
start millions and millions of people
have gone through
and gotten out of debt by going through
financial peace
university they've learned how to pay
off their debt take control of their
money and you can stream all nine
lessons right now
and you get some extra support by going
through the class with others
and the only way to get financial peace
university
is with a ramsey plus membership you can
get rid of the death that's holding you
back and in the cycle of worry and
stress
start the free trial of ramsay plus by
texting trial to 33
789 text trial two three three
seven eight nine our question that it
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings
free samples free shipping and with new
promos they run all the time
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from alex in alabama he writes that i'm
single 25 years old in the military and
on baby step 3b with 170 000
in investments i've always wanted to be
a pilot and i'm halfway
through the process of getting my
commercial license if i stay in the
military
it will take me three more years to get
the license and qualifications to be a
pilot
it will only take four months if i
pursue it full time i'm afraid the
aviation industry will recover
soon and i'll miss the employment wave
so i want to get the license
asap to de-risk my situation burning
bridges in the military and taking a
step backwards career-wise
is holding me back should i leave the
military now to pursue flying
full-time okay there's so much here dave
first of all i'm afraid
that the aviation issue will recover
sooner and i'll miss the employment wave
that's not true
uh there's always going to be a need for
pilots that's a false narrative that's
creating some unnecessary pressure
i also have questions about burning
bridges in the military i don't know why
in the world you would need to
burn bridges if you're leaving honorably
and you're leaving from the military to
go into the marketplace to pursue a
future
you don't have to burn bridges if you're
a jerk and you leave the wrong way
that's the only way you're burning a
bridge so don't quite understand that
you have two options here if you want to
take your time and financially it's more
viable for you to finish out the three
years
or you stay in the military and then get
the license that's fine too
but if you're 25 you've got some good
investments and you've planned for this
financially to go full
time for four months you got to have
living expenses you don't want to go
backwards financially
for the four months that you got to go
full on to get
the uh pilot's license so i don't think
there's a bad decision if it's me
i'm planning for this and i'm going to
go for the four-month option
and i'm not going to look back but you
can't let fear of something that's not
real hold you back here dave
now what i can't tell from the email is
if he has served his that's what we're
not clear on yeah his time that he has
yeah promised the military yeah and if
he's you know you can't just walk out
that's not and i think that's what he's
alluding to that's not burning the
bridge that's just not an option
yeah you can't you can't just walk away
you said i'm go we're gonna serve four
years you're gonna serve four years
that's correct you know so
you know or whatever it is you signed up
for what was your your tour
and so now when your time is up
if you're referring to burning bridges
because somebody's going to get their
feelings hurt that you left the military
well that's on them that's not on you
you just don't be a jerk and you
say i've enjoyed my time here and i've
enjoyed serving my country and i'm going
to move on with my career
if your time is up so if you can leave
without doing something
illegal or breaking a contract and be
done in four months that's what you
should do
yeah but not because the whole aviation
industry is going to evaporate
in the next three years if it's going to
evaporate in the next three years why
are you going into it in the first place
that's a dumb plan you know it's like
you're going to get the one job that's
left and they're never
you're never going to need to right
another thing ever they're going to hire
everybody and
you're going to be the last one no
that's that's that's a completely
false narrative yeah but uh but again it
has to do
i can't tell from what i can't i don't
know what burn bridges means here
yeah it's hard to say i'm assuming he
realizes you just can't walk from the
military
you would think you can't just show up
and ghost them you know like hey i'm out
i think i'm gonna get my two-week notice
yeah i don't think that's the way
that doesn't work that way i don't think
that's how it works all right tyler's
with us tyler is in salt lake city
hi tyler what's up hey guys thanks for
letting me join you today
sure how can we help hey so i just kind
of have a unique job situation so we're
in baby step four
five and six and i'm a professor at a
university
and so they put 15 percent of
of my income through a retirement
account every paycheck
they do free tuition for my kids and
our plan is to get the house paid off in
the next four years
but i wonder if what's what's the i
guess what i should be doing in terms of
that four five and six in addition to
maybe
doing some remodels to the house that my
wife really wants
okay well baby step four is fifteen
percent
of your income going into retirement
right
okay and that gets you the full match
right well see
well they'll so they do that without a
match so they just
they do fifteen percent regard i don't
put in any they put them through
well that's just that's just a nice
benefit okay that's wonderful
but you need to be putting 15
of your income into retirement that's
baby step four
okay you knew that you knew that was
baby step four right yeah i knew that
was
step four i just thought what i've been
listening to you for five years and a
few years ago you when someone had a big
retirement like that you would say
well maybe you do five or seven percent
and throw a little more towards the
house but lately i've been hearing you
say
you know do the full 15 no matter what
they do
a big retirement you mean like the
amount they're putting in or if you got
a million dollars already in there
no so i have about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars you don't have a big
retirement
that's a little no yeah yeah you're
talking about the amount they're putting
in
i i think the only time i have said that
and i
i one of the few things i am is actually
consistent
um so uh i think the only times i have
said
to lower it down to that to seven
percent or something
is um not not based on how much
they were putting in but mandatory
placement like they require there are
some positions where they require you to
put 12 percent into a program that's
like a pension plan or something
and then do i need to put 15 more on top
of that no we back that off or
or they're going to furnish this or that
so anyway you can you can do whatever
you want but i would recommend you put
15
of your income in and that you take care
of kids college
and then you work to pay off your house
and remodel your house out of the
balance
and that's you know that that's pretty
consistently
yeah what we teach so hey thank you
robin
is with us robin is in nashville hey
robin what's up
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call i really appreciate it
i will listen to you for years and years
okay um
i'm cummering because i have an
interesting situation i've been married
for almost 25 years
um live about 10 hours away from our
in-laws and the rest of my entire
husband's family
they own a his parents being they own
a lake house and they came to us
recently asked if we'd like to
buy in they own it outright but they
told us in the next couple years they
would like us to make a monthly
payment to keep it running and then they
would then turn it over to us in about
the year 2023.
my husband and i kind of sat down and
and did the math
and decided to not do that good his
other two
siblings opted in we opted out good
um but there's two there's two problems
there
number one um we're the only weirdos
that
that left the family and left the state
and we're also weird because
we follow your plan to a tea and are
debt-free except for our house
and you're 10 hours away from the lake
house so there's no reason to buy into
it
right yeah but they see it as having a
lot of
money and so why wouldn't we because
it's such a small because we don't want
to
and it's our money correct yes
exactly and now they are going around
the family
telling everyone that we have opted out
of our inheritance
well and i'm struggling how to explain
to them that's not inheritance
i just wouldn't just let them do
whatever they're gonna do
i mean they're just being butts
you can't make somebody not be a butt so
hurt your feelings though but you didn't
opt out of anything you opted out of a
dumb plan
good for you and if they're not going to
leave you something because of that
oh well that's okay move on with your
life i mean it sort of sad
people trying to control people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
adam and aaron are with us hey guys how
are you
good great welcome so good to have you
where do you guys live
not for it in iowa all right welcome to
nashville
so good to have you and here to do a
debt-free scream that's right how much
have you paid off
we paid off 266 thousand dollars
how long did this take took about 13
years okay
and your range of income during that
time we started out about
uh 85 000 and went up to about 195.
wow nice what do y'all do for a living
i'm a
manager release engineering team uh at a
software
company and my wife i teach second grade
good very cool
266 thousand thirteen years that must
mean you paid off your house
we did pay off what's up looking at
weird people
i love it how am i how old are you two
i'm 46 i'm 45. and you did it before 50
years old that is so weird
i love it what's this house worth i
think right now it's probably worth at
least 350. but it's hard to say
very nice good for you how's it feel to
not have a payment in the world
so happy yeah that's amazing
well done 266 thousand dollars paid off
13 years
so you just been working the way you're
supposed to work it just having living
life living on a plan and knocking it
out
so what what's the story of behind this
what got you started 13 years ago
so 13 years ago i was on a business trip
in about 2008
and coming back and i wasn't in control
the radio um and
your show came on um and i had never
heard you before at all but
a lot of it was kind of speaking to me
and listened to that for
probably solid hour on the way back and
uh got home and did
uh did the searches on the internet and
found uh
found what your baby steps were and i
kind of followed that for a little bit
but
we probably didn't kick it in for
another two or three years but
certainly uh we were headed that
direction anyway both of our parents are
very conservative
i think the only thing that would have
been acceptable was a car and a house
payment but
we wanted to get out of all that um we
have four kids
uh they're age 22 down to uh 13 now
and so it was just kind of slow and
steady and and it was
it was hard for us particularly because
i think you know you get into that that
medium income and
we didn't have a lot to cut out that um
a lot of other families might right we
didn't have a lot of
traditional consumer debt to take out
the equation but
um so yeah it was a lot slow and steady
we i uh did fpu i
facilitated that for you guys a number
of times over the years and
uh we did it ourselves that gives you a
boost yeah
it helped yeah it's harder it's harder
it's hard to
not do the things we teach when you are
the freaking teacher
yeah yeah you have to do it it's like
it's like hypocritical weird yeah if you
don't
i'm i don't really do all right no that
wouldn't work yeah
yep that very good i got to ask you
about your
the promotion over that 13-year period
you go from 85 to 165.
95. oh was it 190. oh i'm sorry it could
be my own writing 195.
so what what happened there what was
that journey i yeah i was i stayed home
with our kids when they were little
um and then i did open my own preschool
and i did that for a few years um and
i've done
in home day care along the way to always
earn us some
um extra money but then um i did
start teaching full-time about nine
years ago um
so that was part of that so that
that added a big chunk of it just you
know good
yeah oh yeah no certainly i've i've
moved up i've been at the same company
for 24 years i worked for pearson
education and
um i've had a very successful career
there very happy for it but yeah but
she's the workhorse right even when she
was home with the kids she was
she was kicking butt figuratively
in some cases literally yeah good very
good you guys
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of dedus
i would really like like adam said you
know we
always spent conservatively so um
we probably jumped into our home um a
little bit
um ahead of schedule financially but it
was where we wanted to be
and where we knew we wanted to raise our
family
so that kind of pushed us back a little
bit but it was just a slow
steady race but i am
excited because we did say some no's you
know when
you know other people were doing
vacations or you know
spending a little more frivolously so i
am
our youngest our oldest i'm sorry just
got married
a couple of weeks ago and i'm excited
for you know the next chapter
of our lives and be able to say a few
more yeses
you know to some of the fun things yeah
that's fun yeah you're in really good
shape to do that yeah
you don't have any payments right i love
it yeah
that's so funny i know you're a car guy
dave i uh i've driven a prius for over
10 years now
and uh i have four younger brothers that
would say that was not the manliest car
on the planet but uh um so we've
and i've wanted a truck forever forever
and i've told her about it forever i
have a
young nephew that that would always ask
me uncle adam when you get in the truck
when you get in your truck and i
for a while i told him uh aaron said i
can't get it
and then i had to take that back because
she said because it wasn't true
um but but finally uh last year with
covid and with a wedding on the horizon
another graduation on the horizon i did
flip the script and i
i wanted to wait until after the
mortgage was paid off to get it and i
know that's really not your principles
and
i've heard you speak that a number of
times and we decided to get the truck
last year and
uh and finish off the mortgage this year
that's cool
good good for you that's a normal thing
that's good
that's the way it should go i like this
you guys are heroes well done
you're free you set yourself free i'm so
proud of you
excellent excellent job well we've got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter in your story
you're leaving a legacy to these kids
these
weddings are starting to happen next
thing you know grand babies will be
coming along and life is good man
and i'll go visit papa in his truck
there you go i like it it's good stuff
good stuff also a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away
and pay it forward and get somebody
started on their journey as well
so really good job you guys excellent
work and thanks again for being
coordinators as well
adam and aaron from the cedar rapids
iowa area
266 thousand dollars house and
everything
paid off in 13 years making 85 to 195.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
absolutely incredible that is fabulous
that's how it's done so what we're
seeing ken
over and over and over again are these
what i'm now starting to call baby steps
millionaires the people that have
followed the baby steps
and there they sit with a 350 000
paid for home wow we don't have to we
didn't ask about their retirement
accounts but we know that during that 13
years that they've also been
investing in the 401k because they were
following our steps precisely
so we know there's a chunk there and so
they might not be millionaires right
there today we didn't quiz them on that
but they're very close
and they're and they're yeah and by
their mid-40s they will be yeah
or they're in there they're in their
mid-40s by the time they hit actually
the
every the the millionaire study that we
did the average millionaire that we
studied out of 10 000 and was 52.
wow so they're going to be right on that
yeah they're going to be right on that
and they're you know they're going to be
get their first million dollar net worth
with a paid for home
and with a pile of money in your 401k
following
the baby steps and so we see a lot of
times it's about a third
like you got about a million and a half
dollar net worth you got about a 500 000
paid for house and you got about a
million in your 401ks and your roth iras
we see that pop up all the time with
these baby steps millionaires
it's uh uh but i and it's really
it's not billionaires no if if you want
to be a billionaire
you really shouldn't use the baby steps
because you're not going to get there
ever
oh that's right because a billion is
1000
million so if you have ten thousand
dollars
mathematically on a ratio basis
you are closer to being a millionaire
than a millionaire
is to being a billionaire ah
yeah but everybody thinks of
millionaires as being like the same kind
of rich as billionaires
millionaires don't have private jets
millionaires don't drive 250 000
lamborghinis millionaires don't have
four extra
vacation homes those are things that
billionaires do
now if you want to be a billionaire you
need to use a different formula the baby
steps won't get you there in this
lifetime
but if you want one to 10 million
dollars
and that's your target baby steps will
get you there we heard over and over
slow and steady 13 years they did it
they stayed with the baby steps
13 years and now look at them the best
is yet to be for this couple
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day second
corinthians 5 17 therefore if anyone is
in christ
the new creation has come the old is
gone
the new is here our friend john maxwell
says
talent is a gift but character is a
choice
there you go i mean you guys are
stressed out or hurting
because you've been worried about this
stock market going
one direction or the other maybe uh
maybe 2020
scared you to death maybe you need to
get somebody in your corner like a
conscientious
investment pro to teach you these
are called smart vester pros around our
place they're people that we have vetted
they have the heart of a teacher
they'll walk with you as you learn to
build your confidence and so you can
ride the wave of something like a 2020
or
the different things that happen in the
market and you just think long term and
think long term and think long term
go to ramseysolutions.com smart vester
and
you can find a list of the pros in your
area the smart vester pros and you can
choose one
and pick out who you're going to work
with to put yourself on that track for
baby steps millionaire
all right sam's with us sam is in
shreveport hi sam welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up
i am kind of questionable baby steps
four five and six
uh and my question is about
concerning the investing in 15 of my
income
my employer does not offer any 401k of
any kind
and so i was wondering what should i
invest in after i max out the roth ira
are you married no i'm not
okay do you have any self-employment
income no i do not
okay all right yeah your roth is all
you've got available to you then
you max that out and then if you want to
do something else you just buy some
mutual funds
get with your smart vester pro like we
were just talking about and what you're
looking for there
is a low turnover mutual fund
a low turnover ratio on the mutual fund
like a four or
five percent or less turnover ratio an
easy way to find that is an s p 500
index fund most
of those are low turnover what low
turnover means is they don't sell the
stocks
mutual funds a group of stocks and they
never sell or almost never sell
95 of the time the stocks in there
and so as those stocks go up in value as
a group
you do not pay taxes on the gain until
you cash it out
this is a capital gain is what we're
dealing with here
if the mutual fund sells the stocks
inside of there all of the gains are
activated each year and you have to pay
taxes on it
so when you're buying a low turnover
mutual fund it's kind of buying a rental
property
where if it goes from 200 000 to 300 000
in value you don't pay taxes on that 100
000
increase in value until you sell it
and so that gives you the same effect of
that in a low
turnover mutual fund and that's the best
option you've got left to you
at this point and then over time you'll
probably end up in a different
employment situation
maybe you'll add some self-employment
income which you could then do a sep
uh on this simplified employee pension
plan additionally if you had some a
little bit of extra income
nathan's and amarillo hi nathan welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave hey ken how are y'all great man
what's up
good hey so um i am 21 year old i've got
one year left in college i'm about to be
a senior
and uh i've got about 12 000 sitting in
my savings i'm wondering
uh if i should do something else with it
because i feel like it's not uh
i mean it's just sitting in my savings
i'm not making any money off of it
what are you studying uh i'm studying
energy finance and management good for
you
excellent thank you um
well i mean nathan the you're gonna need
that money to either finish school
debt-free
or make the transition after school
because the transition being a move
to maybe a different city maybe some
travel to do some interviews
so that money is best used to invest in
nathan rather than
worrying about some kind of mutual fund
investment at this point you are a
better investment than a mutual fund is
you're going to make more return on it
by using it
to ensure that you graduate debt-free
and sure that you're able to make your
transitions
without any um it just gives you a
little grease in the wheel right ken
yeah absolutely what do you want to do
you have a good idea specifically i know
the industry that you're headed to but
what would be that great job right out
of college
so that's the thing i've been thinking a
lot about that i'm not entirely sure i
have a
insurance sales job that uh that
has been asking me to work for them down
in college but i'm uh
thinking about learning a trade
and uh hoping to become some type of
owner operator
of uh a certain trade fascinating well
let me tell you not use your degree yeah
that's true
that's very true i'm just one no no
what's the actual answer
i don't know that's the thing is i i
really don't know
what i want to do and i just know that i
do want to do something with my degree
to where i'm
talking to other people and helping
other people i don't want to sit behind
a desk and
not talk to anyone well but when you say
energy finance
i've never heard of that degree does
that mean that you're
specializing in financing in the energy
industry
sure so uh oil and gas uh you know
renewable energy stuff like that
are you interested are you interested in
finance
sure yeah absolutely um i mean i mainly
picked it up because
i uh had enough time to pick up another
major
and uh but i i think that i i like
finance don't get me wrong but i would
like to do something more in the
management
uh aspect yeah so play that out what
trade
i'm not holding you to this but what
trade are you thinking about and then
eventually
working your way through the trade maybe
owning your own business what are we
talking about
so honestly it could be anything uh i've
had
hvac stand up to me just because i've
had a million problems with uh hvac and
the companies that i'm
using and talking to are terrible at
their job and i'm sitting here thinking
that i could run that uh something like
an hvac business
tremendously better than the people i'm
talking to
it sounds like you still got a lot of
searching to do but if you really love
the trades
yourself meaning you enjoy solving
problems with your head and your hands
and then you work your way up and
eventually own your own business
you know and that finance background
that's not going to hurt you but either
way dave's advice is absolutely right
let's say you pursue the trades coming
out of college
you're going to need some of that money
uh to potentially do some trade
certification you need to quit picking
your career based on convenience
yeah and what's just in front of you you
need to start thinking about what's in
your heart
because you you picked up this major
just because it dropped in front of you
and you didn't really give it a lot of
thought yeah and now you're picking up
hvac because you once knew had an hvac
guy didn't show up on time
um that's that's not the way you need to
analyze
this i mean if you want to find
businesses that suck and get into one of
those industries
the entire world's open to you because
there's always in
any industry there's businesses that
suck but let me ask a question
you are intrigued by the trades yes or
no or is this a fancy
no i'm sorry
i mean go ahead no i'm out
are you intrigued by the trades or do
you really like the idea of working in
the trades it's something that
personal interaction with people solving
a problem is that what's drawing you or
is it just a fancy
so ken it's not necessarily the trade
itself it's uh owning my own business
and doing something better than my
competitors
and helping people out along the way
okay all right so you have an
entrepreneurial drive
so you better do your homework on this
because here's what happens dave's
exactly right you just well i've had a
bad experience with some hvac companies
and i'm going to start an
uh an hi company you're going to wake up
six months into that and you're gonna be
miserable because it's not what you
thought it was you better
figure out what problem you're trying to
solve so there's a three-part question
for you
for an entrepreneur to start something
what problem
do i want to solve all right not one
and it's not one that makes money it's
not an industry that needs your help
yeah it's like i have a burning desire
to solve this problem on behalf of
people so who are the people
and the problem that i'm helping i'm
solving a problem i'm helping people
and then what's the solution you get
most excited about in solving that
problem
if you can figure that out now you've
got something that it's not
just a business that allows you to work
for yourself and not work for the man
and if you don't do that you're going to
be a typical entrepreneur
who's jumping from idea to idea every 20
seconds because you have zero juice for
the actual businesses
and so you you run to one thing abandon
it run to another abandon it and it's
just
add in the marketplace thing i know
because i'm an entrepreneur too
and so we all haven't we all have 27
ideas in a minute
it's just part of our the way we're
wired so be careful with that it's very
important to figure out what's burning
inside of you and then go do that
not go look for something of convenience
bad plan good hour ken thank you sir
good hour james childs and kelly daniel
in the booth i am dave ramsey your host
will be back with you before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you